I have a documentary being made about me
now dude I know what do you mean you
know I know why well it's so shocking
but I've been in the game
all right dude you know I mean on a high
level this guy this junkyard dog has got
ribs yeah I don't appreciate you calling
yourself a I'm built the bear down okay
you know that okay sure and so they
followed me around whoo okay all right
so sure that's a little bit secret but
so you can't say guy who's the directors
done some movie all right okay all right
hey you wouldn't know a lot of movies
okay sure
and reason making a documentary but both
of us right it is my so so they followed
me around for a month and they saw what
I did yeah and and they have a title for
my dog no I so shocking because it's so
crazy and I'm like that's so flattering
and I agree with the title all right I
agree with the title because it captures
my essence okay but and I was like how
are they gonna capture my essence sure
okay all right but you brought it up
okay so what is it so the documentary
about Bryan Callen is you all know I am
buddy hall just close we could I embody
the hold on so how is this it's spelled
just kung fu kung foo what you're saying
boom well that's how it's said so as I'm
from I studied in China for so long but
and my Master's okay so they're making a
documentary about you when you train as
long as I have you switch rain as some
years you trained in kung foo and well
don't and you get to a point where you
actually become oh don't know dude you
don't become a saint no either but but
what
harrassing is the way or you're saying
you agree with you though but just say
come my food I'm not the one who told
Steven Spielberg to call it hold on a
second
[Applause]
Jim try to edit that so you're saying
your birth partner you're saying that
you're saying that Steven Spielberg he's
making a documentary about you I can't
say his name okay so whoever you said is
making a documentary about you yeah and
they're calling it gloom foo know what
for boom foo kungfu come full almost I
mean I'm not getting it
coming full bloom foo okay so you're I
mean I'm doing it the way you're doing
there's a little bit of a you as silent
you but you've got you've got to
pronounce to you right again going fool
what so you may go up at the end so if I
were to say let's go and train come for
right come fool
there you go okay let's say I have to
give it the respect right okay but what
but okay so you're a comedian yeah who
can fail you with what with an open hand
that's yeah they're making a documentary
which I would never you okay sure you
have it all right okay so I so so in the
other martial art is you know that I
that I studied for [ __ ] ever
don't say Japanese accent right and
that's that I don't like that right
mm-hmm
no and I and this and I know you trained
right but you know I've trained I am
sick I am training all right you've
trained and maybe you trained still all
right I'll give that I'll give you that
much you know I've for six years did is
you geez you know that I've done for six
years I've done juji's it's like oh you
geez geez I've done juji's right darling
you have to say geez I know I'm saying
but you're saying gee no no I for six
years I know boxes to it you have not
trained long enough to actually call it
jo suji's jiu-jitsu jits I just said
jits
ah that's not yeah all right so anyway
we might have to lock you up right
why go [ __ ] you all right like you know
like it does it count as [ __ ] someone
up if there's no shots or anything but
but but the the guy goes the guy who
loses goes
no dude you you know that I could stop
your heart dude right yeah no I know by
the way you're almost 49 52 and this is
Howard this is this is so how about that
there's [ __ ] peak guys who do
business and like crunch numbers and
[ __ ] and this is our giant what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]